j'accueille andré glucksmann
bonsoir
choix qu à la bombe en gras bien alors
vous publié chez plon
une rage d'enfants dans une rage de dent
non publié chez plon
une rage d'enfants dont le pitch pour et
est comment une rage d'enfant devient
colère de toute une vie en effet c'est
pas une autobiographie classique mais
plutôt un parcours le parcours d'un
enfant qui a grandi dans la
clandestinité dans la france occupée et
qui fuit depuis son désaccord avec ce
qu'ils font comme si de rien n'était
comme si rien n'avait été alors
apprendre les choses départ d'abord
votre nom glucksmann en français ça veut
dire homme bonheur mais la vérité c'est
qu'en fait vous raconter très bien que
c'est l' indice de l'humeur du
fonctionnaire austro hongrois qui était
chargé de nommer les juifs alors quand
il était de mauvaise humeur il appelait
le mec chase man l'homme de merde quand
il était avec quelqu'un c'est normal il
atteler goldman l'usurier et quand il
était de bonne humeur et bonjour il
appelait glucksmann veinards je suis
comme ça que votre ancêtre a été baptisé
glucksmann oui alors il était peut-être
de bonne humeur ont particulièrement
facétieux parce que mon ancien vendait
des vieux chiffons on ne sait pas si
veinards que ça en fait
ben si il était veinards puisqu'il a eu
un monde vénère voilà alors vos parents
donc été tous les deux citoyens
autrichiens il avait quitté l'europe
pour la pour la palestine
évidemment avant la création de l'état
d'israël c'était avant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ils se sont rencontrés à jérusalem ils
sont tombés amoureux l'un de l'autre ils
se sont plus visiblement ils ont fait
deux enfants
et alors ce qui a deux caractéristiques
quand même d'un c'est énorme ce qu'ils
sont venus à l'europe à un moment où
tous les juifs fuyez l'europe
exactement jenson quel courant pour ils
sont retournés et pas n'importe où ils
ont ils sont allés en allemagne
l'ours et 1930 à peu près à l'époque les
ssds à
les toits les rues avec des barres de
fer
et ils sont juifs ils sont à l'époque
communiste et ils ont décidé de résister
à hitler ils ont pensé que c'était là
que se posait le problème est donc ici
sans elles et ils sont montés au front
mais alors complètement à contre-courant
alors ils y vont en plus avec 2 avec
deux fillettes quoi c'est pas avec vos
deux soeurs donc hélas il se met au
service de l'internationale communiste
dans l'allemagne de hitler
jugeons en 1937 ou là ils sont ils sont
découverts il fut à paris et vous vous
naissez à boulogne en fait oui mais bien
bien tranquille français oui français
grâce au droit du sol de la famille
voilà le saint louis alors votre père
meurt en 1940 sur un paquebot torpiller
entre calais et douvres nous dit qu'il
était passager d'un navire bourg et
d'émigrés germanophone est en fait c'est
des gens qui voulaient aller en
angleterre surtout expulsé d'angleterre
enfin bon ils circulaient et puis
finalement ils se il ya des torpilles
qui les ont descendu probablement des
torpilles allemande à moins que ce
soient des bateaux qui se faisaient la
guerre enfin bref on sait personne ne
sait non au lieu des mythes dans ma
famille on disait mon que mon père était
magnifique qu'il était qu'il avait
laissé les vieux prendre les canots de
sauvetage qu'il était resté avec le
capitaine et ses incidences possibles
on sut pas sûr parce qu'une avait aussi
une maladie abrite un pan et donc il a
coulé à pic alors comment l'occupation
vous retrouver avec quatre femmes
votre grand mère en fait qu'ils se
laissent mourir parce qu'elle sent
qu'elle est à un poids pour vous allez
vous dites trop juive trop allemand de
trop facilement vos internautes français
et quand même s'étend dans la france
occupée ce n'était pas vraiment un
commandés et donc les trois autres
femmes c'était votre mère et et vos deux
soeurs voilà mais vous êtes tous dans
l'illégalité c'est à dire que votre mère
refuse de porter l'étoile jaune
pas question d toile jaune et d'idées et
venaient d'allemagne etc mais elle
savait ce qui l'attendait donc à vous
vivez dans la clandestinité entre l'âge
de 3 ans et 7 ans vous avez deux noms et
deux prénoms vous appelez joseph
glucksmann et andré rivière
alors pendant l'occupation c'est la
clandestinité donc que vous dites pas de
foyers seulement des domiciles
l'incertain était la norme
oui mais l'influent j'attendrai pain au
dessus je ne suis pas une grande victime
un grand martyr etc
je suis un homme et je trouve la
situation normale c'est ça que je
voudrais faire remarquer quand même mais
vous vous participer quand même à la
lutte
vous allez fermer une maison vous êtes
chargé quand même de les fermer une
maison où l'on cache des valises darmon
cachent des clandestins à votre niveau
ajouté chargé de fermer la porte à clé
quand il y avait personne dans la maison
ouais et de planquer la clé sous une
pierre un endroit précis ce que une fois
je n'ai pas fais là je me suis vraiment
fait attraper mais la maison était pas
loin de l'immeuble de la milice quand
même ah oui c'était en face c'était
entre le chemin de fer un ami c'est une
des maisons parce que j'ai vécu dans une
vingtaine de maisons aussi dans des
pensions religieuse et aussi à lui à 3
ferrer l'accrocheur c'est drôle zeturf
en quarts ah mais ça c'était pour les
tartines mais aussi pour jouer la
comédie
si j'étais très content alors je croyais
jouer la comédie au fond les bonnes
soeurs devait être au courant le curé
devait être au courant mais on
protégeait le petit grain qui se croyait
très malin
alors quand vous êtes raflé vous est
emmené dans un camp de regroupement à
bourg lastic et là votre mère commencé
aux gens parce qu'elle le savait elle
avait connu l'allemagne
la véritable destination finale de tous
ces gens les gardiens sont inquiètes
et il profite de votre nationalité
puisque vous êtes français pour vous
ranger tous dans les non juifs
il est très fort sire que votre mère a
tellement gueuler quoi qu'il m'en elle
vous a sauvé la vie elle s'est sauvée
exactement ça c'est la grande leçon
première ne sombre mon existence mais je
les sucs après c'est que l'insolence et
la vérité dit paix en fait elle risquait
de panique est absolument tout le camp
parce que l
ehouman et les gendarmes nous ont pris à
part union diffèrent me l'a dit mais
pourquoi je le ferme je dis la vérité
vous le savez plus où moins moi je l' ai
vu je sais que daradji ça existe depuis
donc je sais très bien où des gens vont
et je vais pas leur cacher pourquoi
genre cachent pas ils ont leur 20e là
aussi après la guerre il ya un autre
épisode aussi incroyable c'est
l'histoire des rothschild donc vous
retrouver au château de ferrières qui a
été transformé en foyer pour enfants
rescapés et un joli les rothschild qui
viennent voir un peu tout ce petit monde
comment ça s'organise et là vous jetez
vos souliers sur vos bienfaiteurs tout
le monde est assemblé tout le monde
ville retour de la paix finalement il ya
quand même un autre qui sera établi et
puis je déballe là dedans je jure
personne ne comprend je détache monsieur
sûr je la lance sur des officiels bon on
écrase le coup il avait beaucoup de
gosses se complète beaucoup plus
fou dingue que moi parce que c'était des
gosses qui revenait toute l'europe des
camps de la mort et c'est qu'il m'avait
raconté moi j'avais j'avais pas subi ça
je ne m'en étais même pas douter en fait
c'était mon premier livre
ouais voilà parce que je crois que ce
que je ne supportais pas c'était le
l'idée que la paix était revenue et
qu'il fallait plus penser à ce qui
s'était passé voilà donc première colère
face aux rothschild cette colère ne vous
quittera plus et ensuite votre mère
retourne à vienne parce qu'elle n'est
pas bien en france et là c'est
incroyable vous êtes français vous
restez seul à paris à dix ans avec une
chaussure vous choisissez la france à ce
moment là bas je choisis un pays qui qui
est porteur des idées de révolution qui
est porteur des idées de liberté
à l'époque la france représentait
beaucoup moins c'était le l'endroit où
toutes les nouvelles idées apparaissait
alors c'est pas du tout parce qu'on
était fermée c'est l inverse les
américains étaient arrivés il était très
décontracté nous avait libérés mais il
avait surtout apporter le jazz art et
apporter le jazz la grande littérature
le cinéma et c'est quoi et la france
l'avait bien pris c'était saint germain
s'était hard s'est-elle existentialiste
et tout le monde dans le monde entier
discutait de ce qui se passait entre la
france finalement et l'américain alors
toujours précoce à l'âge de 13 ans vous
adhérez au pc quand même énorme
c'est fou un usager un peu de trafic et
quand même vrai et il y est resté
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans jusqu'à l'entrée
des tanks soviétiques dans dans budapest
en 56 alors vous avez refusé à ce
moment-là lénine staline et vous rechuté
dans vous devenez à l'époque anarcho
maoïste où comme on disait mao spontex
penser que mao était la solution pour
ces noms c'est pas du tout ça on avait
besoin d'une
d'une effigie qu'on ne connaissait pas
pour contrer le parti communiste qui lui
était pro soviétique alors comme les
chinois s'engueuler avec les soviétiques
d'accord bon on pouvait rester
révolutionnaire d'accord et discuter
très fermement avec la cgt de
particuliers alors vous dites c'est
quand même le grand regret de ma vie
d'adulte ça oui c'est une honte parce
que parce que la révolution chinoise a
été une des pires vraiment la pire du
xxème siècle enfin bien deux millions de
morts c'est entre 50 et 100 millions
visite ce fut je l'espère ma dernière
complaisance avec un mangeur d'hommes
d'où le titre de votre bouquin en 75 la
cuisinière et le mangeur d'hommes qui
est un best-seller que j'ai vu à
l'époque que j'ai acheté que j'ai dévoré
à l'époque je dois vous dire c'était un
choc terrible
vous le savez d'ailleurs oui c'est la
première fois donc un écrivain juif de
surcroît comparer le nazisme et le
communisme part ça il ya des gens que ça
a beaucoup raté
c'est pas que j'étais le premier à
parler des camps c'était une chose
connue mais je me suis demandé pourquoi
connaissant cette chose sarthe savait
qu'ils avaient au moins 10 millions
morts en russie soviétique et pourquoi
finalement l'acceptait à gauche et j'ai
pensé que c'était à cause du marxisme à
cause des des bons des bonnes idées des
bons sentiments faire le bonheur du
peuple malgré du million de man etc etc
voilà ça a été les nouveaux philosophes
oui
andré glucksmann villages d'enfants est
publié chez plon
alors quelques questions d'actu andré
glucksmann vous étiez pour
l'intervention américaine en irak
vous êtes contre l'intervention russe en
tchétchénie pourquoi parce que je pense
que saddam hussein c'est bien pire que
tout ce que les américains ont commis
comme crémer comme une horreur depuis
savoir bouchra and one can am ou des
terrains que saddam hussein c'était deux
millions de morts en 20 ans de dictature
que jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'intervention américaine avec toutes
ces erreurs 1 elle cessa non préparation
de la suite
bon pourquoi poutine poutine c'est
l'homme à la tête de l'armée russe qui a
rasé la première capitale européenne qui
a été rasé depuis varsovie en 1944 ces
grosses ni quatre cent mille habitants
alors bien sûr c'est officiellement de
la lutte contre un terrorisme mais y
imaginer que le gouvernement grec rasd
et le faste sous prétexte de lutter
contre les terroristes d'ailleurs ndao
oui ouvrage que l'espagnol rasd bilbao
bon moi je vais pas compris qu'on puisse
rester silencieux devant ça entre temps
la russie a supprimé les libertés qu
avait plus ou moins cor dessine
supprimer les libertés des mass média
devenu extrêmement nationaliste au
mauvais sens du terme
la preuve que la tchétchénie s'intéresse
aussi l'ensemble de la russie et
l'ensemble europe quoi alors vous êtes
pour la publication des caricatures de
mahomet mais contre les quolibets sur
les chambres à gaz pourquoi ben alors
parce que il ya la différence entre une
opinion et un fait les chambres à gaz
c'est un fait c'est tout c'est un fait
alors que l'idée qu'on peut se faire de
dieu et des prophètes
elle est à la liberté de chacun je suis
pour la libre expression
je suis aussi pour le respect des
vérités c'est pour ça que les islamistes
en fait tu parle de religion de la shoah
c'est pour mettre les deux choses au
même niveau
voilà ouais mais excusez moi c'est pas
une question de religion de savoir
ça a existé
alors votre livre andré glucksmann
s'appelle une rage d'enfants envers une
interview rage